okay everyone would you please
put your pens down for a second
and um now you guys i've seen a lot of
fantastic diagrams
a few bits that need to be fixed up
that's okay that was the whole point of
doing it
i want to come back to this one
that i drew in the first place and i'd
like us all to go through the process of
calculating the area together so if you
did not draw this at the beginning when
i was talking through it would you
please sketch it now below where you've
got your one we're all gonna do this one
together
and then you can go ahead and you can
work out your own areas okay
okay i'm gonna be really quick
so remember we went outside we recorded
these numbers you then went ahead and
you constructed this diagram and then
you're like okay now i see a sort of
bird's eye view
of the shape that we were doing okay for
me the particular one that i've divided
up because i have one two three four
offsets
that means i have one two three four
five six
shapes that i need to work out the areas
of okay because you can see you're going
to have three on this side from these
two offsets three on this side from
these two offsets some of you did more
offsets some of you did less
obviously the more you have the more
accuracy you'll have okay
so i'm going to quickly label i'm going
to call these i'll start from the bottom
i'll call this
one
two
three and i'm numbering these as i
progress through as i did the offsets
right because this is the first offset
which gives me this area this is the
second offset which gives me this area
and so on okay so i'm numbering them all
so i can speak about them unambiguously
okay and now i can start to calculate
let's look at area one
okay area one is a triangle right
triangle is base times height over two
you're going to be doing a lot of these
formulas so rather than writing out the
formula i'm just going to go straight to
putting these numbers in okay
remember we said you've got all these
right angles that means that either of
these could be the base and either one
could be the height okay so all i need
to work out every one is base times
height on two
it could have been ten times eight
doesn't matter does it okay you'll get
the same number eight times ten of
course is eighty so you divide by 2 and
get
40. fantastic so there is my first area
and i'm going to progress through area 2
also a triangle
also
base times height over 2 but be careful
right the height here is composed of two
lengths 10 and 13 which gave me this 23
right so when i do base times height i'm
going to go 20 by
23 all the way across
and that's going to be divided by 2 okay
i could multiply and then divide but it
makes more sense to divide first because
that will just make that 10 be a really
easy number to work out 10 by 23
230
okay and now it's area three which is my
first trapezium so we did trapezius a
little while ago probably helps you to
remember that the area of a trapezium
we developed its formula we proved it in
a couple of different ways with slicing
up the shape in different ways
is h over two
so
perpendicular height have a look at this
uh this trapezium here
what is the height of this
trapezium it's going to be this this
this is here isn't it 13 plus 5 that'll
be the 18.
18 over 2
and then i'm going to multiply by a plus
b a and b
are the parallel sides right so it's
going to be eight plus 12 which is 20
which is a bit convenient so you're
going to get 180 meters square
you're going to continue for area 4 area
5
area four area five and then you'll have
a total area which of course will be the
sum of all five and then you're finished
okay